went back to the old the old digs yeah
well we did the five year anniversary in
my old place so we gotta do this
something
yes exactly five years something five
years something in your place yeah and I
was actually surprised to find out that
you still had the lease on this place
yeah you didn't you didn't tell me that
no well what happened was um
uh some people moved in here and with
our Newfound success I evicted them oh
oh so you bought the building I bought
the building raised the rent got
everybody out of there
everyone in the whole building everyone
in the whole building oh wow yes there's
no one here so you didn't just raise the
rent on this place to get them out you
just I wanted everyone so that we could
shoot this yeah
wow they can come back next month yeah
okay rent is ten thousand dollars a
month uh per room oh yeah really yeah
wow so three bedroom is only going for
like 30k a month yeah which who knows
that much you know that could be a steal
yeah right now depending on what the
market is yeah
at the time that this releases which we
are definitely recording in real time
this is recorded in advance this is not
recorded months in advance no no of
course not this was not recorded in
anticipation of your wedding yeah yes
which may be occurring this week
hopefully close to it hopefully yeah
that'll happen all things go to plan
hopefully yeah it's gonna happen let's
talk about bulldozing El Segundo I like
yes yeah yeah so this is our plan
assuming assuming we get elected for
City uh planner no I mean your guys even
if prop 27 has passed
which it may have passed yes I know that
prop yeah yes of course yes yeah use the
prop foreign gambling yes it is yeah
gambling that really is the only one I
yeah
um well Cody voted no on Prop one and he
doesn't know what that means and that's
even funnier I feel like that's bad yeah
Cody you just told me that's the
abortion one yeah yeah Cody's uh
extremely against prop one he has no
idea what prop one is uh again I'm
assuming that's bad yeah yes so I'm
gonna disagree with that
with what you just said
yeah so this is our plan guys now that
prop 27 has passed we think
um hopefully we yeah God willing we are
going to take a certain pocket of
California called El Segundo if you
don't
know where this is or what it is
if you're a listener and perhaps
Portugal
El Segundo is this beautiful Portugal
yeah if you're from Portugal okay so
this is just just for the people
listening from Portugal no I'm trying to
paint them in image like if you're from
just the people from Portugal though
oh yeah because English people aren't
real okay okay yeah so okay sorry
continue painting if you were
you know
um if you could imagine a beautiful
stretch of land
filled with
um such a useless conglomerate of things
you know Office Buildings that
have you know UH 60 stories and only two
of them used by an old e-commerce
company
yeah wait which one
uh oh you don't know I kind of might
have been like eBay or something no you
couldn't even tell I couldn't even tell
you okay that's how old it might as well
be eBay yeah it's like who still uses
eBay yeah you know and how do they even
there's a there's a weird diverse
there's a weird division of live Journal
left over in there somehow they're still
going you know and and let me just say
this too the roads are really big and
wide there's a lot of like land over
there for some reason so right now it's
being utilized for these big like
unassuming kind of like sort of
depressing Corporate Office Buildings
and fast food places yeah it's one of
those two things yeah
but recently
they put a Topgolf in that [__]
they said uh we're gonna take this piece
of land right here and build something
fun and interesting and cool yep and I
feel like this could be the start
of a sort of like entertainment wave in
that whole area especially now that we
might have gambling legal gambling in
California we were just talking about
imagine [__] Caesar's Palace wow yeah
[__] uh the Paris one
yeah I think it's just called Paris
Paris Paris yeah Paris Casino yes pow
pow the the uh where you know uh carotop
plays yep [__] Luxor
with the replica Eiffel Tower as well
yes
yeah
I mean
I would love to have sick casinos here
well because dude then you'd have okay
you could have mini Vegas right there
and then that la
a monorail that they're building for the
airport okay because you know the Metro
is going to connect up
like the metro line is going to connect
up to that line to take you to the
airport in some years so there's gonna
so imagine now if they just build some
extra track for that monorail from the
airport yeah and it just goes down to
105. yes and spits you out on Casino
Boulevard yeah
no but then it goes through the New York
hotel and does the roller coaster yep
yep that's part of it yeah you're coming
from the airport with your baggage and
stuff like that and also you're on a
loop-de-loop dude imagine how thrilling
that would be and then it spits you out
right at the Aria I hate this I hate
this because it's a reality that we're
not gonna get
and I hate fantasizing do you know how
much I would love to take an Uber fly to
Vegas lose a bunch of money fly back in
on a monorail and then go to Casino
Boulevard and do the same thing yeah and
then double up and make all my money
back well how are you supposed to win if
you don't keep playing right exactly I
mean just a simple math yeah imagine
like you have a bad day at work and so
you go just hit the slots 16 or seven
hours
like
there's no better way to decompress in
that
damn you sit in traffic on the 405 just
get down there to Casino Boulevard and
like [__] yeah yeah end my [__] you know
your wife said to you where are you I'm
at Topgolf playing the golf simulator
yeah with um that has
um the golf themed slot machine no
there's a golf simulator but it has it's
got cash bets in it I'm just hanging
with some guys that I met yeah and I'm
just betting on holes
just
I'm at the sports book at Topgolf
watching horse racing
just betting with these random dudes I
don't know okay well
um my tits heard from breastfeeding so
if you want to come back at any time
let me know
I would love it if you came back my my
titties hurt so bad as soon as I get our
retirement funds back baby I'll be right
back okay I wonder if your tits hurt
after breastfeeding
yeah I think they do it's not a thing
because babies go crazy
apparently it like really messes up
their nipples oh because they look yeah
they like suck really hard
that's why I can't have a kid why don't
be jealous
well I mean like there's still one like
the baby's on one you could you could
hit the other the other yeah might as
well even them out
make them right
well you know I mean you can't have just
one nipple raw babe yeah
well you know it's not like nipples are
perfect you know a lot of ladies walk
around with one that's slightly
different than the other true you could
you could use the baby to to round you
know to round it out yeah
make the other one a little bit less
aligned yeah yeah I see what you're
saying so then then they become perfect
yeah
and then you go in there and you mess it
up again exactly yeah
you said you're gonna be jealous of the
kid maybe yeah yeah let me get your
mouth off my [__] lady what was I
listening to some podcasts where they're
talking about
or something where they're talking about
drinking their wife's milk I just saw
someone um
what's the [__] guy's name he's like
a famous actor from like uh Mark Rober
yeah the famous actor Mark Rober yeah
from uh squirrel yeah um whatever yeah
um obstacle course yeah
American squirrel Warrior
no it was like Casey he's from like one
of those like werewolf shows or whatever
but there was a video of him doing it he
had like he poured it into some of his
coffee and then drank his coffee
apparently it's like sweet yeah
are you gonna drink some I mean come on
what yeah
gotta find out yeah no I'm really
curious I've had people jokingly offer
it
you know like oh there's some in the
fridge you want to try it yeah I think
you told me this one time oh no didn't
you what store did you tell me that one
time no that was at least we saw that
story on tour no basically
it was um did we on stage yeah this is
like a very very early no so
I walked in on what is who is my now
sister-in-law I walked in on her
breastfeeding
and it was an unintentional thing I was
just going upstairs to use the bathroom
and I like turned the corner and I made
eye contact with her with her titty out
and I was like and
my nephew just you know yeah fueling up
going to suck Town yeah and I just
I just cranked my head so hard to the
right I've felt massively uncomfortable
right did you say anything I was like oh
yeah I didn't see nothing she kind of
laughed we both sorry we both were like
[__] that was weird
and then we kind of laughed it off but
then what happened later say something
weird like
he's really going to town yeah
sorry
dude then we go downstairs and we have
cookies I think okay
and then I went and got milk
and then it was just some weird like you
know it looked like some weird Freudian
thing oh I see well you know where I got
the milk because I'm thinking of ah but
it wasn't actually no no no okay I
thought it was like in the fridge no
yeah you thought it was titty milk yeah
right yeah no no no no no no but I just
then someone made a comment about me
drinking the milk and I was like damn
I don't know if I can drink this milk
anymore I feel really weird
yeah
yeah dang
that kid is four now holy [__] yeah
grown ass man damn still breastfeeding
nah dude